Goooooooooooooooooooooood
Good morning gamers. It's another beautiful day. Oh my gosh. It's actually night in Minecraft we have-
Dark Jöergen... And everything is great, everything is fantastic.
Couple of changes,
Couple of changes, let me show you in here..
As you can tell, I haven't fixed- I haven't fixed the door yet, I'm working on it. Okay, they're sleeping. Hello?
So this is how you sleep; just standing on top of other people. Oh look at him.. This is how you guys sleep? Just-
Looking up. They just couldn't animate their eyes getting closed. Oh,
Yeah, Brad is back
That's right. He's not editing anymore
I Don't know where you came from. You've been gone for like ten episodes. Actually. Let me let me go to sleep as well
Oh my gosh, Is that a CaT?
All these People just........ Appear Unannounced
Quiet kitty I have a cat for you
Let me just make a couple beds because they keep fricking I didn't ask for this
Let it be clear. I okay. I did ask for a lil frickin, but not so many fricking where is the kitty?
Freaking sound is that? *Curious* Hello. Come down kitty. Oh my god. It's kind of cute tho
Oh No, you die now
What they fell on their feet. Oh, maybe there's two cats
Okay. Okay. Okay. Oh, this one is cuter. I like this one more. Hello eat *like the stranger in your mom's story*
Love me
You ate the thing. Oh my gosh. I'll do more fishing later, I guess
I don't need to kidnap people if their kids decide to stay here as well, right?
So these guys trade infinity, which you guys told me
it's actually pretty good and if I don't trade with them I can just
Take this out and replace
It and it should actually change
somehow their profession again, but only if I haven't traded
So let's let's try and do that see what happened. This has now became a library
This is the weird. What happened to this? Alright, does that mean you change the looting one? No?
Feather falling. Okay, so that one changed silic touch. Okay. That's pretty good
But what we are looking for is mending. So let's just keep bed changing. I didn't realize it would be that fast
They just go up to it and wait punch Hahhaha *Cute Skratta*
I Like to punch you, what do I enchant that gets punch?
Heheeeeeee Hahaaaa
Got 'em
DJ cow I think that's probably more uh
I this is a probably a better name than what I what I used to give him in the meanwhile
Well, let me show you Sven what I got
If you put infinity on your bow now as you can see
I have 27 arrows and I shoot an arrow at the tower of whether she
Still got 27 arrows. I have infinite arrows. How did I not know? That was the thing?
Alright Sven we're going let's go
Spend we have stuff to do today. Come on
Wow, you are very slow. Wait. Is that another cat? Ah
I forgot my fishing rod
Give me that Teddy stuff. I love this area. Now. It's so cozy Sven likes it too. He's just struggling a little bit
Just a tiny bit
He's a little bit slow. It's fine. We are all we've already we've we've all
Apparently you guys told me that you have to let these guys out
Because they need to go and frik somewhere else. Damn. Look at these boys. I got so many scutes from them
Damn alright, alright
I'll let you go. I'll let you go. Yeah. Oh, sorry, you've done your purpose. You've done their purpose you can go now
Where is Sven? He's swimming look at it. He's swimming
Absolute brain lit. Alright fine
I just need to go - lets go - Felix. Oh, I just I just really gotta make it
Okay, give me fish for once I want they should know treasures right virgin toad
So today's episode is as you may have guessed water. Oh, look, they're escaping water really related
We have a conduit which we can use to build an underwater base and we for our quest to kill up
Unbreaking 3. All right, you're almost there Sven, you're almost there
We can build an underwater house and we are on the quest to kill the Wither, one of the bosses in Minecraft and
To prepare we need a trident
Which will drop from one of the water people  *coughs* DROWNED
First I want to cat though
All right, let me see here what Oh looks like it caught the big one whoop bet it's really big
Stop
Get out
So apparently cats are really good in Minecraft because they can scare away creepers
Which sounds like a good thing to have at your base, to be honest, and that mushroom stew tho *makes weird Felix noises*
Straight from the titty a
stick
What? All right get out get out
All right, Sven. Let's get out of here. I know do you don't like the kitty cats neither do I but
They're helpful. Okay
I'm really good with cats guys *looks for cats while making weird noises*
Where do you go?
Hello cat
Hello
Neko, Doko ni imasu ka (Cat, where are you)?!
Is that what you do?
You just sleep all day, why are they always more of you as well? Where're the cats?
Why are there another one SIVE IS HERE I must ask Council of sheep for guidance Oh council of sheep
Give me guidance on what to do. I should dig down? *GREAT ADVICE FELIX*
Find diamonds deep below
Spank blue sheep's BUTT *FAMILY FRIENDLY FELIX* no, I'm not gonna do that
it's weird. Very well dig I shall. Dig straight WHAT? (ᴚO⊥∀˥∩WIS ᴚƎᙠ∩⊥ ᗡƎ⅄∀˥Ԁ ᴚƎΛƎN ƎΛ,∩O⅄)
not near
There second what?
There's like a secret cave in here Wow, whoa what the Sheep built this cave
What
That's so crazy. I wonder where this goes
whoa
The ball of ah, oh it's an ambush
Whoa, I made it out alive. Thank gosh
Okay, Wow diamonds what their sheep thank you
Listen there's one thing everyone in the planet can agree on is
Mining diamonds look freaking sweet. Okay, so I saved it for the episodes
And we got five. Are you kidding me? Come on
Are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me? You're letting me down man fortune three, let me down
If this continues I'll have to put a down payment on my house. I almost forgot the most important part
We have the turtle helmet now, which will make any water related activity a lot more epic. Okay
So now it's time for you and me
classic adventure
Let's go gamer I put the boat on the wrong side of the tracks I
Am a genius. I know. Thank you
So yeah, just a couple boys
Sven has a shield
What is happening
Why do I have a
What this is my texture pack, that's awesome
What?
That's so cool. Oh
We found one we found one he's shooting at Sven is perfect drop your Triton now or there will be consequences
now or consequence
He dropped it right away
Yes
When we rule the school of where's the boatsman? Ah
Watch out for that sweat. Watch out for that said. Yes, right. Keep your nose up. You're fine. You're fine. I'm not panicking
I'm not panicking where they both go. There's another mushroom biome now wait, we've been there before
I'm starting to think. I'm the luckiest unlucky person in Minecraft
Because all the drops are just insane, but all my loved ones are gone
Come here Smith. You're the only one left
Again, I lose you again. A bear to be without you. That's right
Same foot same pose Papa gotta go floppy snappy. All right
Look how fast I can mine underwater now
Because I have the helper
Okay garbage, but then can eat so it's okay and there's another one
Unbreaking 3 I guess I can take that so many of you were like, oh you have a trident Felix. It's in your
It's in your summerhouse no, I lost it
okay, I lost it from
Another one. Okay. I'll
run, oh
Don't you dare him?
Are you okay eight?
They freaking destroy your boat do they're crazy. They're dangerous. I lost it from one of the water temple and look
There is one literally right outside our spawn and I feel like we should
We should take over it not just beat the bosses
Not just pee pee poo poo
I mean full-on take over it claim it as ours put a conduit in there make it nice and cozy
Put a little fire
honestly considering how many pet I've lost the fact that Simone is alive is nothing but a miracle
Hey look Phoebe poopy is doing great
There's still so many places I haven't even discovered him mine crime I
Haven't been to the snow areas. I haven't found a coral leaf reef weeds
Just getting started fam. There's so many more people I wanna kidnap
This is a dangerous place man. I'm not gonna lie if you had a scuba diving suit
I wouldn't hesitate to bring it because I know how powerful you are underwater underwater
Sven is like a freakin savage
But I need you to hold down the fort for me buddy. Okay, so where do we build the condo then?
Stop I
Say we build it underneath right
Did I not bring any doors I went all this way and I didn't bring any doors, I'm an absolute
Maniac got to make sure I don't do this wrong then. Oh
God this is really bad Oh God Oh God
I need teddy milk fast. Hey you are hey you teddy?
More
More teddy. Thanks
You know what they say if you ain't got doors just make them
That's the expression. No one brought a door through the party. We'll just make your own fan. That's the expression
Hey forgot to make your doors just go to the woods cut them down and make them yourself. That's the expression
Right Sven. Oh
Yeah, that's right, all right BAM we have door the door situation is
All right, we got to make sure this condom it's activated oh
My god this oh god, it's happening again. I remember why I don't like this place
This is a bad place and I wish I had a baby right now
There's a bad place and I wish I had a baby
I'm going back to get my baby
What are you looking at?
I keep killing them, but there's just more and more and more and more and more and it's so stressful
This is more all the time
Let me set up my conduit that's all I ask and to drink my titty juicy piece I said
All right, I need to dig that yeah, I
want to set up the conduit I
Have doors on my side. What are you sponges?
Okay, if I said it went great I would be lying not gonna line oh, here's the one of the bosses oh
It's my super bowl I
Haven't finish
This arrow still do the same amount of damage
No
Yes to to go, baby
Say oh that
Craziest thing that's
A look - down there
Dang it's so hard to find the last one. Oh my god. He's right there
Okay
You're about to taste a knuckle sandwich
So you do the same damage the error just doesn't fly as far
Look at his little tail your loser. I
Can't believe this is an actual strategy I'm using come on
Yeah, Oh
things are about to be a little different around here from now on this town is called puta pack town and
Nothing else all year all
Right. So now what we can do is we can drink the milk the titty
And there will be no more
Debuff that makes us so I can't mine and stuff which means we can take these
Back down. Oh
My god infinity is the best. So yeah time to clear up the space BAM
Water be gone fan don't want to see your face
sayonara Aquos on
First the water flowing from I don't know why this is so oddly satisfying to do
it's like
Weird ASMR. Ah
Oh, that was good
Yeah, Oh it's sinking by
Finally I can bring Sven back in here. Oh
My gosh I did it
Yeah, first room that
Feels good, dude
Now we can peacefully get the gold for a year again
Now I can just tell people I built this place
And no one will know I
Watched watch this. Oh
Oh, are you guys in here? Oh, sorry. What's this? What you guys home? I think I'm just gonna spend some time playing this out
I'll let you guys know when it's finished
So yeah, this took me about an hour to clear out
Then I finally plays down the conduit so that's cool
Then I decided to big a tunnel back to my spawn then I realized that tunnel
Was in the wrong direction
When I finished up the the right tunnel and that's where we're back baby, okay, so three hours later
No, it didn't take that long. We are back and it's time for me to do something. Actually. There's something I want to do first
Wow, what a nice village. Is it only you left getting boat?
There's no escape
Get in the boat just do it. It's the only way Oh God
Got him caught another one spin
Yeah
Stop moaning
Look Jurgen
Caught another one. There's a wall and I can't go in there just
Wait your mind about to be blown
That's right. This is your home now
They're all sleeping, that's so cute. Let's be careful not to wake them up wake up
Battle stations, that's right. Gather here. This is what I wanted trade me good stuff. I
Said good stuff knock back. Get out of here impaling
That's what I have when your mom
Knocked back that's what your mom do when I am your mom
Okay, so then
It's time for me to show you something Austin
Follow me buddy. There's gonna be cool. Hey Sven remember in like Episode nine?
When you were caught underneath water
And we were all so scared
Well now we rule the water, baby
That's right Sven
Look at this so awesome. So but yeah, I got the whole thing
completely dried
It's so dope. I
Also have the conduit as well. So even if I go into water full night vision full breathing
Does that work for Sven as well? That'd be so cool
Get the out of house
Yeah, get him Sven. Yeah, I guess ready. Yeah. Yeah freak him up incredible job
You can get him spend you can get him
You did it spend good job
So yeah, just to show you guys the whole stay the whole thing, baby
It's so satisfying to use the sponges. Why did I do this? Because I can
That's why
Now I was saying like a lot of people do this and then they keep this as their main hub
I don't think that's what I want to do. I just wanted to see for me
It was like a bucket list. Try not to get lost in it could be dangerous. All right
Well, we should head back because we have some other stuff to do. But yeah, the conduit is in here
It is tempting if I should get it back actually
Yeah
Look at that. Yeah
We rule the oceans thing I am Poseidon the Poseidon has the Trident right the god of
The Greek mythology god of the ocean. Apparently it was going to be decided between Hades. Who's the god of the underworld?
between hit cuz they're Poseidon Hades are brothers and
When it was decided between them who was gonna rule the underworld and who's gonna rule the ocean
they were always in such competition with each other that
When he was announced that Poseidon got to rule the ocean. He just went yeah
Frick yeah, even though that's not necessarily what he wanted
He just wanted to shove it in Hades face and Hades did the exact same thing beyond the world yes, that's awesome
That's what they want to rule some random
Greek mythology in the PD pilots minecraft letsplay why
What would you guys prefer to rule the underworld?
Or the ocean, I'd pick the ocean
So yeah
I built this thing here because I thought it could be cool to build a track in between the houses coming from Ikea tower
God, the game likes whenever I come here. I
Think it's time to fight the weather soon
So it's like please
there's something about
baby
We're back gamers. So it's about dang times that I enchant my try to do. I have it channeling
Yeah, it is blunt. So yeah, this will give it channeling
the enchantment
Which means that once there's a thunderstorm
Once I if I hit the pigs that will be turning to pig soldiers, which we're gonna use to fight the weather
So now we just have to wait for a thunderstorm
basically
Obviously, we don't know when it's gonna be thunder. So
It could be days. It could be years. It could be tonight who knows trade me good stuff
pick a job you pleb I
Just realize since we have the sponges we could literally dry out this in ocean
what I do want to do actually is I want to
Maybe place the conduit here
That is definitely not right and we got to add it here
And now we can just chill at the bottom of the ocean for no reason whatsoever
What the Sheep would be so proud of me. Hey, look, here's the chest thing
One of the first thing I found I can appreciate what a meatball from the ocean now
Look, I'm just like you damn he raped though
Damn, turtle beer if does break down
Whoa, no one talks about that. Whoa
Are you serious?
How was this in my map?
Does it go to this surface? Whoa?
So cool
Look how dark it is without the water. This is how it actually looks like I
Keep putting down torches I
Know my man, just digging gold underwater. That's whatever
So yeah for no reason at all
This is my house
Underwater house, can I sleep? Oh my god. I can good night gamers
What a great sleep I mean bloob bloob bloob
Maybe I'll build something that starts from the bottom and goes to the top
That might be cool
Look Brad inside this here. Alright, let's see if they finally have decided to be useful
silic touch that's
That's what I have with your mama, okay, I think for this little
Town to work out. We need to expand just a bit
Yes, go in there
Yes, things are I get about to get the little stricter around here get in the back
No
Packet it do your job
Your job and stop complaining you could be anything if you put your mind to it look this guy became a bed yes
Yes, don't talk to each other
Stop talking
Another one bites the dust. I don't pay you guys to talk to each other say I got the trap doors just so I can
Okay Sven, welcome to what their sheeps lovemaking central first of all, here's our our village
look he
Became amazing now so I can change the trade of these just by placing a work block in front of them
Hopefully in a second same with this one. I just removed it and he just became a normal one
So I want to obviously expand this so I can trade with a bunch of different villagers. So we have I introduce to you Sven
Don't worry. It's double-sided glass
So they can't see us you can looks and it's a lot it's miracle of life when he doesn't one
Is that gun to you and too young for this?
It's okay. They can't see through the glass. This is the freaking shape
No, you don't belong in freakin chamber get out
How do you even get in friend get out of freaking chamber right now
So for them to freak they need to think that
There's beds around them like extra beds and I think trapdoor makes it so that they can't go
But they think they can go I think that's hot don't look at me like that. All right. Sorry. I'm not here
I'm not here. I'm not here not here not here
Don't worry. No one sees you
So they need to eat 12 potatoes
- Frick, so we're just gonna they don't see me. They don't see me. They don't see me
Make sure he eats all of them
Make sure the other guy eats all the parts
eat the potatoes
The potatoes and do whatever they can't see me because I'm behind the glass. Oh
Okay, okay and now they should be able to frickin spend
Just don't weigh
Villager freaking is like milk. It only happens to win that you're not looking
No, wait, that's not the expression. All right, so you changed your blast protection. So it is working
He's a farmer how ah I have to actually go back to the flower place one second
Okay, we're back here because I need a couple more pink ones
It's a very strange episode
Cottam
Have they fricked yet. Come on guys. Do they need another bed, man? Yes
Another one
Yeah, get him Sven Oh No sit sit
Don't hurt them then stop. They were put Spanish murdering spend his roof. Let's stop it
See 10 see see he's sweating. You're crazy stop stop stop stop
Sven I need them
Spend you absolute savage
Don't look at me like that, you know full well what you did. Oh
Don't tell me I let's also not forget the gold
For our number one boy
our golden boy
Isn't that right spin?
So if you guys remember in the jungle, we had this really weird area with flowers everywhere
Which is just what I need for a little something-something
They're gonna love this
He loved picking flowers more than any
Swedish man picks up flowers, lo lo look look
God damn so many flowers. It's raining
Please be Thunder a
Pirate ship on top of
On top of the water. I'll take it Thanks Oh
Perfect. I need trapdoors
I'll show you what I'm doing in a second
Right now I just need resources
Whoa, a third treasure, Dan. All right
what rich I
Got too many flowers
What do I throw away now that I found a treasure map I have to find it obviously
Suffering from success and we find another one and
Suffering, oh my god
Come on, what their sheep make it thunder?
Iceberg. What is that?
Said Jesus on the cross in Minecraft
Why whoa, wow, I've never seen snow in Minecraft
So pretty
This is so cool, if only spendin uragan conceived I went to pick flowers and it got all crazy
They should be here somewhere in this piece of sand, all right, we'd be digging. Oh
Yeah
Bit easier than it used to be
There it is so easy
Yes
Come on Thunder, what does she please I think
It's a day later and at last at long last you
Decided to trade me mending. Yes
Hold on let me get my purse your again. I have mending. Oh my god the cat finally
Mending or cat
Get the fish all they're all cooked the salmon needs to be raw
Yes, I can't wine
Get out of my way Turtles I need to fish fast why
This is taking too long, I'm going in Swedish style
Get in the bucket. Yes now we put you on land and they would chop you up
That's how you fish in Sweden kit, please be dammit
Next time
Don't blow this. Oh
My kid work right away, yes
Yes, and even right next to mending, baby
Let's give elaborate at this. Yes, and then this Loretta
It's pouring
Hula Britta purring
All right gamers. This episode has gone on well enough. Oh, I did everything I wanted to
I'm so happy
Isn't that right ? Hola PITA ?
Lula Britta meet Sven
Thank you guys for watching another episode smash like if you enjoyed check out the merch I really really appreciate it. Thank you
Will we defeat the wither next episode will I get the enchantment for my Trident watch next episode to find hat?
Thanks for watching guys. Bye. Bye (Sublitles By Shunover and others...)